I got an email this morning summer gig
they're offering you 2500 a day details
are sparse but it's definitely VIP you
must be Sir Jackson you must be Ethan
let's try a practice test we'll see how
you do
so we are having a boy
what's your dad do
I'm not allowed to say
what about your mom
[Music]
how's work well the kid's giving me
sort of a strange Vibe they're just kids
Ethan they can't help if they come for
money even if they're a little bit
messed up what about the baby is it
planned how do you know about the baby
he's obsessed with me in a total stalker
sort of way
Jackson hi I'm Annie
taught you you must be a really special
person this needs to stop right now
assaulting Jackson you're scared of you
there are some pretty substantial
bruises on his leg Jackson gave himself
those bruises I needed this job I have a
baby on the way I'm gonna have to let
you go how was your evening Ethan lost
everything thanks dude we stay away from
my family or I'll hurt you
[Music]